- I don't wanna talk about it.
- [Interviewer] You don't wanna talk it?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Why not?
- 'Cause I used to be a ho on Figueroa,
I used to make money.
- [Interviewer] Let's take off your mask.
- Hey, hey, I used to make
money like a motherfucker
in Figueroa.
(sniffs) I used to.
- [Interviewer] You did?
- [Candace] Yeah, I did.
Can you imagine making
three grand every night?
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Candace] I said,
can you imagine making
three grand every night.
- [Interviewer] You made three
grand a night on Figueroa?
- [Candace] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How'd you do that?
How many guys is that?
- That's a lot.
- [Interviewer] That's a lot.
So how do you go from
Figueroa down to here?
- How did I got downtown...
- [Interviewer] You were making
$3000 a night on Figeuroa,
and now you're here on Skid Row.
- How did I get down here?
- [Interviewer] Shoeless on skid row.
- How'd I get down here?
Running away from home.
- [Interviewer] It didn't have
anything to do with crack?
- I ran away from home.
(sniffs)
That's how I got down here.
Well anyways, yeah.
I got raped.
So I wouldn't want
nobody else to get raped.
(sniffs)
- [Interviewer] You got raped recently?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] By who?
- By my auntie's
ex-boyfriend, Tall.
His name is Tall, too.
He choked me.
He covered my mouth.
He just... It was horrible.
Like I said, I wouldn't want no woman
to go through what I just
went through yesterday.
(sniffs)
Can't talk, tonsils be all swollen up.
Lungs all swollen up.
'Cause you can't talk
because the motherfucker done
messed 'em up.
- [Interviewer] He was high?
- He was high.
(sniffs) Yeah, he was.
He was too high, I think.
And then, you telling us
you gonna call the police.
He get scared and run off.
(sniffs) Yeah, he was
too high, (sniffs) yeah.
(sniffling) Yes, he was.
- [Interviewer] So where are you at today?
You're living in a tent still?
- Yeah, I'm still in the
tent, but not for long.
Hopefully God'll give me an apartment.
(sniffs)
My sister and them don't
want me down here no more.
My auntie (yawning), my
auntie is a bus driver,
and I talked to her on the bus.
(sniffs)
She said, she's gonna
get me from down here.
If I don't get from down
here, she's gonna come get me.
(sniffs)
- [Interviewer] What are
you doing for money now?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] What are
you doing for money now?
- I'm 'bout to stop doing everything.
(sniffs) This is not a lifestyle.
- [Interviewer] When's the
last time you got arrested?
- I haven't been arrested in a long time.
I ain't trying to get arrested (sniffs).
I have to turn my life around.
I don't...
- [Interviewer] You still
working with a pimp?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] You still
working with a pimp?
- I don't got no pimp.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you
had one a little while ago.
- Yeah, that was a long time ago.
That was when I was with Blue.
That was when I was with Twists.
My man that I'm with right
now, he's not no pimp.
That's my personal, personal husband.
My man, period.
I don't share him, I don't
do nothing, he stay home.
He go out there and make
his money, I make my money.
We put it together and
we get, we's a team.
(sniffs)
No pimping here.
I do it because I wanna do it.
- [Interviewer] Where do you
see your life going in...
- You know how I see my
life going in three day-
next year,
is hopefully I'll be in my own apartment.
(sniffs)
And I hopefully I would
have my own apartment
and my kids back, and go back to school.
- [Interviewer] Your
kids are where right now?
- In New York with my sister.
(yawning)
My plan is, that's my goal is
to get myself together (sniffs)
and to get my babies back.
'Cause I need them.
(sniffs)
No, I didn't put my kids up for adoption.
No, I did none of that.
I wanted my babies.
(sniffs)
I was fucking up, smoking too much.
With my daughter.
Woke up smoking, kept smoking.
And my water broke.
And I had my daughter, you know,
at the terminal, I meant at the Cecil.
(sniffs) In the hotel.
- [Interviewer] How many
years you've been living
on the street?
- (yawning) I've been
downtown since I was 17.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- (sniffs) 36, I'll be
37 next month (sniffs).
- [Interviewer] You
still using a little bit?
- A little bit.
Not that bad like I used to.
I'm gonna stop doing everything, man.
Because this lifestyle
is not the same no more.
Lord have... Too many
people getting killed
somebody and
I can't do this no more.
- [Interviewer] It's a hard life, right?
- Yeah (sniffs).
I can't do it no more.
I'm getting old.
- [Interviewer] So if you
get housing down here,
and you bring your kids down here,
you think that's a good
environment for your kids?
- I'm not gonna bring my kids down here,
because I don't want them down here.
- [Interviewer] So you're gonna
get a place somewhere else?
- I wanna go somewhere else
where there's no drugs,
my kids will have a normal life,
I have a normal life.
Everybody be happy.
I just wish I could just change
the whole world (sniffs).
And stop everybody from smoking crack,
and just start and make
everybody a home (sniffs).
- [Interviewer] Do you
think there was something
in your childhood that
set you on this path?
Led you down here?
- What, in my childhood?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I came down here when I was 17.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
but was there something
in your childhood that kind of like-
- I think something's telling me
to come to gettin down here for a reason.
I did it because these kids is teenagers.
When my age was my age.
Like that is going
through the same situation
that I went through (sniffs).
So maybe it's the reason
why I'm down here,
to show them the way to get out.
- [Interviewer] Through these videos?
- [Candace] Through the videos.
- [Male Voice Offscreen] Maybe.
- [Candace] Maybe.
- [Interviewer] I mean, some kid somewhere
is gonna see this, right?
- [Candace] Somebody is gonna see it.
Maybe my kids.
Maybe somebody else.
Maybe who knows.
Maybe somebody in this lifestyle
would look at these
movies- shows, my story,
and change they life around.
- [Interviewer] That'd be great.
You're doing a good deed
by telling your story.
- [Candace] Yeah.
I'm trying to help them, show them,
what I've been through,
I wouldn't want them to go through.
- [Interviewer] Because
what kind of things
have you been through?
Been through prostitution.
- [Candace] I've been prostituted.
I've been raped.
I've been beat up.
I've been choked.
I've been stabbed.
- [Interviewer] You've been in prison?
- [Candace] I've never been to prison.
- [Interviewer] You've been in jail?
- [Candace] I've been to county.
I've been there, all that (sniffs).
Never prison (sniffs).
- [Interviewer] You've been robbed.
- [Candace] Huh?
- [Candace] I've been robbed.
- [Interviewer] You've been pimped.
- [Candace] I've been pimped.
- [Interviewer] A lot of horrible stuff.
- [Candace] Yeah.
I've been stabbed when I
was six months pregnant
with my daughter.
I don't want nobody to go through that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(sniffs)
- [Candace] That's it,
that's all I can tell you.
That's all.
- [Interviewer] It's a
terrible life, right?
- [Candace] Yeah, it's a terrible life.
Oh, and yeah, my ex-husband got killed.
Thought that he died from pneumonia.
No, he didn't die from pneumonia.
- [Interviewer] What would you say
to a 10-year old girl
looking at your video?
What would you say to her?
- A 10-year old little girl?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
12-year old girl, whatever.
- 12-year old? 12?
Do not go through this lifestyle.
Don't let no pimp pimp you.
Don't let no man tell you
what's right from wrong.
Don't let nobody control you.
You got your own life.
You know what to do,
and will do what's right and what's wrong.
(coughs)
- [Interviewer] What about school?
- And stay in school.
You definitely gotta stay in school.
'Cause I stayed in school.
I got a high school diploma (sniffs).
But stay in school.
Get your life together.
Don't have no kids.
Don't definitely have no kids.
- [Interviewer] What would
you say to young parents
that are like maybe
considering splitting up, and they've got-
- Okay, let me tell you.
Parents.
'Cause I been through it.
My dad left my mom when I was 17,
when I was a baby.
Parents, y'all definitely
gotta stick together for your kids.
- [Interviewer] That's a big one, right?
- That one, that's deep.
'Cause my mama,
my dad, he left my mama when I was a baby.
(sniffs)
I never met my dad.
- [Interviewer] Did you say-
Oh, when you were very small.
- When I was very small, small, small.
(coughs)
So-
- [Interviewer] Your dad was
out of the picture, then?
- Yeah, he was outta the picture.
I can tell you right now, parents,
you parents got to stick with
they- stick with together.
That's the only way they're
gonna stay together.
And that's for them kids.
(yawns)
For them kids, you gotta
stay together for them kids.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(sniffs)
Those are words of wisdom from Candace.
- [Candace] Yep, all my wisdom.
- [Interviewer] I think
you're right on the money
with all of that.
- [Candace] Amen.
That's all I can say.
- [Interviewer] (laughs) Okay,
thank you darlin'.